I'll get right to it who are you dating
I'm not dating anybody that's right
there's no hailey no Sophia no Nicola
and definitely no Selena
Justin Bieber tells Ellen he's single
and feels no need to mingle when you're
on the road do you ever go on tinder I
don't know have you ever been on tinder
Kevin you healthier than I've ever seen
you thank you good for you I feel strong
yeah you look strong let me see this
justice seems to be focusing his efforts
on his fitness cameras catch him leaving
ten goofs boxing gym in LA over the
weekend and he takes a moment to get the
prime paparazzi a piece of his mind when
somebody gets in your space it doesn't
really matter who you are if you get
into somebody's personal space you know
anything can happen that's Justin's dad
Jeremy at the Toronto premiere of the
documentary he produced called
bodyguards secret lives from the
watchtower hosted by the concierge Club
he defends his son who's still facing
backlash for punching a fan in Barcelona
two weeks ago
but Jeremy's glad Justin knows how to
defend himself from the dangers of life
in the public eye you're always worried
as a father regardless of what they do
if they're out on their own you know
whether they're in school or traveling
the world it's I think it's the same for
any father so you just worry the way it
is and as for that onstage announcement
he made about social media
you know it is what it is it's social
media and I mean it's it works both ways
[Music]